Speaker 1: So, of course, we're still very
much dealing with the coronavirus pandemic,
and in the midst of all of this, the United
States now has a monkey pox scare where 200
Americans are being monitored and tracked
for the rare disease, monkeypox, more than
200.
Can you imagine what's going on?
More than two hundred people in twenty seven
US states are being tracked for possible rare
monkeypox infections.
They fear people may have come into contact
with the Texas man who brought the disease
in from Nigeria earlier this month.
The man believed to be the first monkeypox
case in the US since two thousand three was
taken to a hospital but is in a stable condition.
So far, no new cases have been found.
CDC is concerned passengers who were on two
flights the man made may have been exposed.
He flew into Atlanta, Georgia, from Lagos,
Nigeria on July 9th before taking a flight
to Dallas, where he was hospitalized.
The chances of the disease spreading on the
plane were low because passengers had to wear
face masks, important detail that shouldn't
be ignored.
If you don't know much about monkeypox and
I didn't know that much about it until I researched
it today.
Monkeypox was first discovered in nineteen
fifty eight.
There were two outbreaks of a pox like disease.
So pox like chicken pox, smallpox pox like
happened in colonies of monkeys that were
being kept for research.
That's where the name Monkeypox came from.
The first human case was recorded in 1970.
And when we talk about contagious disease,
we talk about the natural reservoir, like
where is monkeypox right now?
It's not known, but African rodent species
are suspected of playing a role in transmission.
As the BBC article stated, the first US case
was in 2003.
There have been only 47 cases ever in the
US.
Two hundred people are now being monitored
and that initial introduction in 2003 is believed
to be because of a shipment of animals from
Ghana.
In humans, the symptoms of monkeypox are similar
to smallpox, but not as serious.
They start with fever, headache, muscle aches
and exhaustion.
The main difference between smallpox and monkeypox
is that with monkeypox, the lymph nodes tend
to swell the incubation period, meaning the
time from when you are infected to when you
have symptoms is typically seven to 14 days.
But like with all of these things, it's on
a bell curve and it can actually range from
five to twenty one days within one to three
days after the start of fever, there will
often be a rash, often starting in the face
and then spreading elsewhere.
It tends to be a two to four week illness
in Africa, and this is a horrifying number
in Africa.
Monkeypox has been shown to cause death in
as many as 10 percent of those who are infected,
10 percent.
And that just again brings us back to so far
the mortality, the lethality of covid is under
one percent.
And we say imagine if we had a flu with an
eight percent mortality rate or a 10 percent
of the virus enters through broken skin.
Even if the skin isn't visibly broken, it
can enter through the respiratory tract.
Mucous membranes, meaning mucous membranes,
membranes, meaning eyes, nose and mouth.
Animal to human transmission can be a bite
or a scratch.
Preparing meat, contact with bodily fluids
and the most common human to human transmission
is primarily through large respiratory droplets.
There is no proven safe treatment for monkey
pox virus at this time.
Antivirus antivirals, as well as vaccines,
immunoglobulin or Viji can be used to try
to deal with severity or symptoms.
So this is like the absolute last thing we
need right now.
And of course, because the most common human
to human transmission method is a large droplet.
And right now, because of the covid pandemic,
passengers on flights are required to wear
masks.
The hope is that none of the 200 passengers
that have been identified as exposed will
actually end up being infected, but not exactly
the news that we were hoping for, that's for
sure